Ariana Fuentes Diaz his death could
easily have been prevented it wasn't an
act of God or some freak accident it
wasn't even a random crime the kind that
inevitably occurs in a country as big as
ours is now her death was the product of
a deliberate policy our leadership
classes decided to downplay the threat
of ms-13 why because Trump attacked
ms-13 therefore in the demented zero-sum
calculation of permanent Washington
ms-13 must be virtuous the enemy of
Donald Trump must be my friend that's
how they think it all started almost
exactly a year ago when the president
said this so when the ms-13 comes in
when the other gang members come into
our country I refer to them as animals
and guess what I always will keep in
mind ms-13 s motto is kill rape control
they routinely torture and murder high
school students they bring drugs across
the border and into our neighborhoods
they're the deadliest criminal gang in
America and yet once Trump attacked them
the left decided that worrying about
ms-13 was a greater threat to our values
than the gang itself anyone who
criticized ms-13 was denounced as a
racist if not a tool of Putin they said
as much out loud including on this show
the traditional democratic party the one
that represented blue collar America
would have been baffled by this
working-class people of all colors are
always the biggest victims of crime if
you want to protect them don't side with
criminals that was something that
Democrats including a young Joe Biden
once understood intuitively but no
longer today criticizing ms-13 would
mean asking questions about the party's
orthodoxy on immigration it would expose
Nancy Pelosi's absurd lie that every
single immigrant is impressive and must
be allowed to stay in the country
no questions asked nobody on the left
wants to talk about any of this so
instead they just defended ms-13 he
basically seems to assume that everybody
is part of ms-13 very strange to hear
with president nighted states speak in
such dehumanizing terms is it
appropriate for a president to ever call
anyone an animal even if they are
sadistic gang members yeah I think
that's something to watch out for the
history of political leaders
dehumanizing opponents even criminals
and using animal metaphors is a
dangerous one that is not something that
we should accept from an American
president I do think the serious problem
with the president the humanizing any
group of people in the United States
even if they are hardened criminals got
that saying rude things about ms-13 is a
quote serious problem unlike say
abortion up to the moment of birth which
is liberation and not a problem at all
that's Nancy Pelosi's position closely
considers late term abortion as
wholesome as a 4th of July picnic but
criticized the Central American gang
member with a face tattoo and she will
give you a long lecture about God we're
all God's children there's a spark of
divinity in every person on earth and so
when the President of the United States
says about undocumented immigrants these
aren't people these are animals you have
to wonder it does he not believe in the
spark of divinity the dignity and worth
of every person every day that you think
you've seen it all along comes another
manifestation of why their policies are
so thank you main that's today's lecture
on Christianity from Nancy Pelosi the
media of course dutifully amplified
Pelosi's message he's their boss that's
their job voxcom produced an entire
video designed to explain that actually
ms-13 members are just like your kids
when you think of this street gang ms-13
what do you see maybe something like
this or this but what if I told you the
typical ms-13 gang member in the u.s.
actually looks like one of these young
men on Facebook the ms-13 members that
I've been following our working
after-school jobs they're living with
their parents they get around Long
Island on bicycles there's no indication
that we're seeing
bigger surge of ms-13 than we seen in
the past when the revolution finally
ends when this era this moment wherever
in whatever Rin right now and it finally
ends that video you just saw from Fox
com will be worth watching a period
piece we're gonna look at that and say
it's hard to believe that that's real
but it is real that kind of propaganda
where powerful people are lying right to
your face again and again and begin it
happens a lot and it would be pretty
funny actually if the stakes were lower
but they're not low they're high left
defends ms-13 because they can't
acknowledge it downside to the open
borders they've given us once we start
talking about all of this who knows
where it might end so instead they
lecture us about dignity while high
school kids get murdered and for them
that's a small price to pay